I know this is the last presentation so
I want to try to stretch it out as long
as possible
um what I'm what I'll be talking about
today is scaling semi-supervised
production grade Sr on 200 languages
um just a little bit context behind this
uh well I was thinking what should I
talk about on this conference and what
should I cover so people cannot you know
what is the I what is the pipeline idea
uh the information that I can give to
your audience that they cannot find
really well structured on medium and on
the internet right so I wanted to give
some value
uh so in this talk I'm gonna be covering
how it looks like to scale as ASR and
well from self-supervised side of course
in a production grade setting so how do
you make a product that will you know
help users you know that will have some
users and you know scale it uh a little
about about myself um deep learning
research lead at assembly AI I thought
bragging about four stuff would be a
great idea to do so uh and yeah here's
my GitHub LinkedIn uh email in case you
wanna
give it back
um so how the pipeline looks for a
single language basically we have like
some amount of steps that we have to
cover to make a product that is firstly
efficient secondly it could be validated
to use by users and thirdly you could
reiterate over time so you just you know
yeah
sorry
so you don't have like a legacy code
base and model structure that you won't
use in the future uh first thing is data
acquisition right
this is an important step even before
doing the base model estimation uh we're
gonna cover base model and research and
everything in next steps as well uh data
acquisition means that you have to
decide what scale will you be fighting
with right so if you're aiming for a
language let's say Hindi where it's a
really small amount of Open Source data
probably you're gonna have it a hard
time optimizing the model on a
semi-supervised training stage
uh Second Step is base model training
this is a step which is not actually
practiced in many companies as I seen
Academia and you know in even from
production side of uh pipeline as well
what this means as is we're gonna cover
it a little deeper of course in the
future slides but as a cover information
you need base model to determine where
where you are today with some model that
you decide to use and some data set it
that you could find in as a MIT license
so you can use it commercially or some
data set that you have bought already
you need to cover these steps so the
company knows what money and what
resources they should invest now to get
something and how much should they spend
afterwards and what is expected and how
good can you do it scaling and what
instruments can you make in the future
uh third step is well what I call like
human back prop uh well what it means is
you do a research
and yeah you arrive at some conclusion
right okay let's use this model this
amount of data I don't know these hyphen
parameters initially which is a base
model then you do testing and you do
tuning and you repeat that at probably
like 10 20 times because as much as
experience you have
even if you don't use semi-supervised
learning but if you use semi-supervised
learning models are becoming really
sensitive to certain hyper parameters uh
we have seen like 13 15 order rate
differences across the languages with
using different type of parameters which
is really huge
so this part takes most of the time
actually
actually and uh one thing that makes a
company uh actually better than others
is not reliant on Research it's reliant
on compute we're gonna cover that as
well as a cover information on this as
well
you need more compute to do many part of
experimentations to fail faster find
many things much faster so you can
outrun other companies who are
struggling with compute because they
cannot do the same thing as fast as you
can
and then you do optimization because if
you have an engineering team in the
company if you're like in a middle stage
for instance or even high Stage Company
like late stage companies there's a
probably an engineering table tell you
no we cannot deploy the deploy this
because either it's not scalable it's
well scales really slowly uh takes up
huge time to load or it's not optimized
it takes it's not efficient to run it
because it will lose money at the end of
the day and yeah many things including
accelerators and so on and last is
deployment of course
uh this includes refactoring uh
packaging everything and making it
really smooth so when you look at your
cut six months later it would be like
why did I write this right so it could
be reused by other people as well this
is for a single language
this is worth 200 languages right you do
the same thing for 200 libraries well
this is a little bit dramatic of course
because some things are automated
for instance base model you just once
and you do testing for one language you
know multiple languages based on some
range of Piper parameters that you
already acquired in the first let's say
two three experiments so I know what
grid to search for like you know Search
for really Edge different things you
have some you know base idea what you
should optimize
um and yeah it doesn't take 200x the
time and energy and money and compute to
do this but it doesn't take like 2x as
well like it's a huge struggle to
accomplish this
uh so let's cover what we can do as a
company uh how can we step you know plan
everything what steps could we take to
be able to scale you know ASR on it many
languages
yeah
yeah component one data of course
the first bullet point is kind of
subjective many people might not you
know accept it but this is the kind of
conclusion after working for five six
years in uh deep learning I have a rap
too like model performance it costs 50
of researchers Talent 25. domain data
and 25 computes
why is researchers had the top priority
I mean you can see the big companies or
the companies who are growing really
well are investing a lot into
getting really good researchers and
keeping them right why do they do this
it's not like you know uh just a kind
thing to do that that things think
benefits both sides right companies need
really good researchers to scale and to
think about some ideas that hasn't been
covered yet
uh as an example for instance Google
Facebook I'm sorry was able to
get the same order rate on one hour data
with way to whack as deep speech was
able to do with like 10 000 hours of
data right well these metrics are not
exactly as they should be but it gives
you idea right so really good
researchers came up with uh pre-training
uh idea and like model architecture that
you could utilize so when you fine-tune
it on Downstream tasks for ASR it gives
you the same accuracy as you could get
on tens and thousands of tens of
thousands of our hours of data like four
years back
uh 25 domain data
well sometimes you arrive at a
conclusion that data is data and I mean
let's use everything we can there are a
lot of papers some of them came out
recently that say that actually they
show that
all of your data is not really usable
but probably around 30 40 percent of
your data is garbage even though you
might have some specific data what is
the chance that you have domain specific
data for 200 languages very small right
probably you're using like open source
data set which are either
were initially academic they are not
noisy they are not designed for
production use so your models will be
pretty much learning really clean and
hard to say that easy speech so they
won't be modeling the same thing as they
will meet in the production
and 25 computes as I mentioned earlier
you need to continue to do experiments
really fast so and do things in parallel
so you can
Brute Force lay with the help of some of
course predictable things such as like
scientific experimentation and with like
good researchers you can achieve more by
having more computer other people
uh yeah all data sets are not domain
specific and lead to lower performance
of course uh and companies who have like
much bigger amount of data they will
probably beat you if you don't think of
anything else right because if you take
really terrible model and you train it
on huge data set it's kinda gonna do the
same as really really great model on
really small amount of data set right
uh and companies with extreme compute
have better chance at getting better
results well we have seen all the papers
from big companies including like uh
neural search and to like parallel
experimentation or like predefined uh
iPad parameters what it gives you is
well a normal thing that you encounter
in your life if you have bigger
resources you can do more failing and
you can do the human backdrop well
basically it's your you know you're a
model and experimentation is the data so
you optimize yourself what to do as much
resources you have
um
it's always to hire annotators by
yourself rather than buy data or
outsources so if you have an experience
with working with companies to acquire
production grade data for ASR
you have read an email with a price tag
on it and you thought like
this much for 100 hours of data this is
crazy right
that's why making an annotation in
in-house I mean you don't have to sell
to yourself with margins right so you
take away all the commercial uh
commercial stuff that other companies
are giving you on the price tag so you
can do it more efficiently in-house and
it will be cheaper it will be faster but
it's like creating new company in your
company so there's like management
Logistics you have to do some web stuff
as well because where are they gonna
annotate all these things right and
probably you can optimize many things
during annotation when doing everything
in in-house
um
what we are looking for when acquiring
the data
domain specific data set this is the
most important thing we have to look for
for sure
well if you don't have an access to
domensity specific data set you could do
augmentation right and by augmentation
usually what a person means is okay
let's the frequency masking that let's
do time masking and that will help the
model to you know
learn better be more robust because
you're doing some sort of augmentation
which is not a good idea most probably
uh
time and frequency masking are the most
popular augmentations for speech as you
can see in the papers and in from the
companies as well from tutorials from
blog posts so on it's not really good
for either type of models we're gonna
cover that a couple of slides after but
why it's not a good idea is that when
you're doing time masking you're
basically straight you know stripping
out something some part of the audio
right so the model has to predict
something which is not there
well it's good to force the model to
have a better context and for stage to
model actually the language inside the
speech so if you have I don't know H and
O model can learn okay this word
probably is like hello so it gives a
higher competencies over the ell
right but what this leads to is your
model will be hallucinating at the end
of the day and that's okay thing to do
if you're not doing production or if
you're not using the models in
production because in production models
have to transcribe many things that are
named entities
you're probably it's probably easy to
you know do hallucination over some easy
words that you can hear many times right
but if you're predicting some let's say
I don't know name of the city or name of
the person or address Hallucination is
not a good thing to do there and in
addition to that when you're doing the
deck cutting like language model or
scoring uh as a later step it'll be
you won't have a good predictions
initially to restore right so the
alphabetas that you're using to use
models confidences and language models
confidences they're not gonna probably
help you
yeah uh the component two the base model
uh
well
as I mentioned uh I
I don't actually see maybe that's my
problem but I I don't see companies
actually using base model approach uh I
Know It's Tricky some things are really
hard to do from experimentation and
research point of view because I mean
human nature is not designed for really
harsh logical thinking and sometimes you
think okay I mean deep learning is
really intuitive right maybe I could
guess couple of things and maybe
probably those things are going to be
really good to use later stage or if
it's gonna struggle us we'll think of
something else
that that's a great thing to do if
you're a solo researcher or if your
company doesn't have to scale this
service on many languages and with many
uh important customers but if you can do
that if you have to do that
you have to estimate your base model
because of couple of reasons firstly you
will be having a easier life and your
like colleague researchers will be
having user live secondly it's gonna
cost to accompany much less because it
will know we're standing it will be
easier to predict what resources really
need how big your should team grow for
the next I don't know like a year and so
on and plus you can
taking calculations for data sets and so
on and so on
the choosing base model is really
hard well it's it's terrible job to
accomplish because well you know it's an
initial stage right and you have to say
I'm betting on this model and this will
be really good based on experimentation
right and probably we're going to be
able to scale this
well it's taking huge responsibility
right
but I mean there are some hyper
parameters then we can optimize even by
intuition
well firstly model types encoder
Transformer conformer convolutions a lot
of types like CPC rnt well let's cover
only like mostly really popular
losses and model types then number of
parameters probably have seen like
we have trained 175 billion part of an
ugly model as you know as a papers and
so on and so on
you cannot really do that when you're
doing an like multi-language production
ASR because that's gonna struggle you
and scale in terms of scaling you won't
have the same margins because you your
cost of the services will be huge and it
will not be hard to reiterate because
it's gonna take I don't know like two
months on age a100 to train like a 2
billion parametric model so it's about
deciding
what do you need and why you should go
with some number of parameters maybe you
could just say let's have lower accuracy
for now but as we have some more
customers we can make the models bigger
we can add features charge them more and
so on so on and learning rate and the
scheduler and freezing of phrasing which
was actually firstly pointed out in the
wave to act paper
uh
as a really important thing to do so
turns out that during semi-supervised
learning we need to take the model and
use it for Downstream task it's really
sensitive how you update the weights so
you you should use pre-trained weight
somewhere and you have some randomly
initialized weight somewhere you
probably don't want to have the randomly
initialized part drive all the
optimization because it will do huge
weight updates initially and the weights
in the upper model which has already
pre-trained weights is gonna disappear
or change by you know a few steps you
don't want to do that so it's important
to know how to do unfreezing and
freezing and that's of course
experimentation
and pre-training
um
in the same company components how to
estimate the base model
well there are a couple of questions you
could ask yourself which will help you
arrive to a conclusion what to even
experiment with right firstly
a small data set is not really good for
rnnt translucent models why because they
are well much better at modeling the
language like
not speaking literally but
uh so if you have really small amount of
data sets transducers tend to overfit on
the words that are in their you know you
know uh training data set and it will
have really hard time predicting name
entities uh during the inference and in
production and that's really terrible
thing to happen because your company
wants I mean your company wants to
transcribe everything that's you know
other company is looking for right and
probably those most important things are
some main entities right because of you
know marketing I don't know like
personal information reduction so on so
on
uh ASR is a really complex task task
right it's not a
you know it I would say it's like on a
higher scale of complex tax tasks uh but
I mean
in these scenarios when your task is
really pretty complex you can say that
having more polymers will help never get
better results right probably you'll
agree with me but there's a thing to
decide uh
and that this is not like exactly for an
engineering standpoint right if you're
in a startup going with high parameter
Network as I mentioned earlier it's
gonna cost your company a lot so you
have to decide okay should we like spend
huge amount of money right now on
scaling these huge models yeah and will
that help us getting the customers in a
time frame where we still have money and
then we can start thinking about
optimization or you know let's just
start with smaller models because you
don't have but didn't didn't yet find
market speed and you'll just go from
there and make your products really much
better with extra features and stuff and
not brag about order rate and you can do
all the optimizations of accuracy later
on
um
if you
if you have small amount of data
self-supervised free training is the way
to go right
[Music]
I mean probably most of you have uh read
or hear about heard about uh rivers and
developments in ASR and
let's say web 2x which is really pretty
much the most popular uh self supervised
for training you know model
um with way to work you can do huge free
training on like unlabeled data set and
then you can use like 10 minutes of the
specific language data set and you can
get pretty decent order rate
well in terms of Academia right for you
know if you have academic training
setting if you have academic validation
set which is really crazy and which is
really cool so if this exists why not
use it for fraction right and if you do
use it the models are really really
sensitive
as we mentioned earlier how you update
the weights and which weights do you
update well it's a huge role where model
is going to converge later on
um
okay and
after you you know ask this couple of
questions to yourself and arrive to some
conclusion and you have initial idea you
do some experimentation then you say
okay this is my base model now I can
search for a couple of pipette
parameters and probably it's gonna make
it better that might be batch size that
might be learning right that might be
phrasing authorizing schedule and so on
um
yeah component number three uh this is
where companies are spending the most of
the resources so if you have the initial
model the base model or let's say you
have already deployed model but you say
after six months okay we have to
reiterate this model because customers
are saying that it's struggling at some
I don't know identifying like named
entities let's say right so you have to
make it better
how you do it is again probably I should
trademark this one but it's a human
backpack basically the same cycle so you
train you actually tune something you
change you do some estimation probably
it's struggling because I don't know
like we don't have enough named entities
in the language right or maybe you can
add extra loss which is like named
entity CPC loss right so named entity
word loss right so you do the CTC and
then you calculate your named entity
order rate and you do that you add that
as a coefficient right
and you train the model and you do
evaluation and uh actually the human
icon here is not by an accident yeah
evaluation should be done by metrics
objective metrics but by subjective
metrics as well why
because word error rate and character
ever erase or word information uh loss
is not uh
everything that you need to say we
should really deploy this bottle right
because it's really hard to identify if
your model is better at really something
really specific and small using these
metrics so what you need here you need
to do subjective estimation right
you know look at the outwards like I I
bought them I don't know like that the
difference checks uh you need the
subjective parts of the evaluator as
well to say okay yeah this release
specific thing is kind of fixed so we'll
probably okay to deploy this or it's not
as good as we thought it was and we have
to uh do the tuning and training again
uh so yeah this cycle is where the most
of the you know resources are spent
averagely and uh as big as you have like
each component of this cycle it's
it it's uh so bigger the better in this
case as well if you have huge resources
to train the models well you can
identify better ideas much faster than
other companies because well you have a
ton of gpus uh if you have like
researchers who can evaluate or for
instance or contractors who can evaluate
the output subjectively um you can do
the same you can move fast forward and
you can say that the same for analyzing
and tuning as well most important part
here
app from researching standpoint is
tuning of course which is a really hard
thing to do and like from personal
standpoint I feel like as more time I
spend into deep learning more I think
that
it's really up it's really hard to uh
intuition intuitively estimate uh what
will be the outputs
um
yeah we have a really small time uh left
because I don't really have a sense of
time sorry for that so we're gonna go
for two of you know a couple of frames
really quickly uh this is TBT Trend
validate tune basically
like some companies say no okay let's do
a couple of training runs and let's just
deploy it really quickly and that's okay
thing to do initially but if you do want
to make a huge steps during you know as
a researching company or uh as a you
know production oriented company you do
have to invest in this of course because
you you can't move really forward if you
don't have many choices to choose from
um
yeah which model do I need
um just as a you know some medium Story
cover uh we have Transformers and
conformers as you know best things to
use pretty much right now as an encoding
bottles right uh Transformers are really
good at catching long dependencies they
are easy to pre-train and is it easy to
find here and we have been using it for
like some time already and we can we
actually know them really well at this
point but
conformers are Transformer plus like
convolutional layers right and ASR if
you think by its sense is actually a
local problem because you're classifying
each frame right yeah the probability of
the characters so you can use that local
attention which could be provided by
convolutions and you can boost that
features by locked and different
dependencies with Transformers
uh self-supergent MLM contrastive even
adversarial losses uh
with self-supervised free training you
can make your models much more robust
for sure how you can do that you can
thank huge amount of data which will be
production level data because you don't
need them to be labeled so you can crawl
YouTube and so on with like Mikey
licensed videos and audios and you can
do pre-training on them
which will make the model's weights much
more robust so when you do the fine
tuning on a not so robust data set I
mean it's gonna compensate a little bit
now yeah about losses I'm covering the
uh frames much quickly as I mentioned
because we have small amount of time
left uh CPC and rnnt losses prob like
personally I'm a big fan of rnt if you
have enough amount of data like
transducer is the way to go of course
it's really elegant it's really robust
towards noises and like some adversarial
things that you can't see in your
training day during your funny fine
tuning but it's easy to overfit our 90s
it's harder to scale and optimize which
is the reason why CTC is better if
you're not if you don't have all the
hyper parameters optimized from
engineering research and even business
side right so you have if you have to do
quickly uh iterate quickly probably
you're gonna be better off with CTC
because it's easier to optimize it won't
overfit and it's easier and scalable to
tune
uh the last part is optimization
probably you can remember these logos
right on an extensor T and the last is
torch neuron which is like inferential
uh from AWS Etc
um
well what are the differences in between
this accelerator Frameworks
uh tanzarote which is called uh yeah
like 10 RT runtime three-time runtime
well tanzarity is really really amazing
uh accelerator the problem is that
you have to optimize it for specific
model specific input size and specific
Hardware well that takes out most of the
uh things but most of the slowdowns that
come come from other uh accelerators
because you can't predict the
computational graph really well and you
can optimize the kernels how to you know
move the data in GPU so you're not
restricted by a speed of light and how
to compress and fuse the layers so it's
harder to optimize and harder to scale
but it's much faster than anything
uh onnx is uh a little bit slower than
in terms of RT because
um I mean you can use multiple backhands
right so you don't have entirely
pre-computed computational drafts so you
can use Cuda and you can use tensor RT
as a backhand right so uh and you can
have Dynamic axes as well so you can
change batch size change second sequence
length this kind of kind of trade off
that onlx gives you if you don't need
that extra 20 acceleration you can you
know use this uh
torch neuron which is like AWS inference
yes compiler for the models are by the
way like really really cool
thanks to you know use but
the idea is that it's hard to estimate
what you should be using
from hardware standpoints and uh you
know how you can scale it
what I mean by this is you can use the
infinite instances such as like
multi-core multi-threading you can just
take one model and make replicas over
the you know PPU parts that influential
comes with I'm not sure if it's legally
the exact word I should use TPS but you
know optimize Hardware so it's kind of
engineering and business standpoint as
well so what should I do like which
inferential instance should I use for my
model so it it I know that it's hard
harder to decide compared to other uh
accelerators but it will be much better
off
probably by optimizing everything in
advance
and like investing a little time ahead
because then while you will be doing
scaling in a long run like let's say
next year two years well you will pretty
much know everything you have to know
and you will be knowing like what is the
optimal things that I can use to
increase the profit margin and keep that
you know scaling easy
uh yeah let's uh actually this is like
last two uh
slides I wanted to talk about the
deployment part as well which is I have
an engineering background as well so I
I'm really cautious about things to do
in machine learning that will be
deployed yeah because you know then it's
not easy to sleep when you do some
decisions that is gonna struggle
engineering right
so first thing first is open source
Library dependencies it's not really
it's easy to use open source libraries
for experimentation and like initial
deployments but
it's not good idea to rely on high-level
open source libraries because they're
gonna struggle you in the end because
some things are gonna come off for sure
that need a custom you know I don't know
custom paths you have to do something
really really custom and you will have
to write I don't know extra 2000 lines
to just support that uh but if you had
use like pie torch for instance in pure
part or you can you could do the same
for I don't know like 20 lines because
you know it's a fundamental core Library
like really low level in Python terms
Hardware Choice uh
some Hardwares are really really
expensive so just let's say a100s but
we should not be afraid of the price of
GPU per hour what should we looking
forward to is cost benefit ratio right
because let's say a 100 comes with
really high price but you can do all the
really amazing things it has high vram
you can partition the GPU if you have
small models and you can replicate one
model on you know many sub gpus and plus
they are much faster and they come with
all the efficiencies which if you
calculate with those efficiencies the
price perspective they are not I mean
they're pretty you know efficient at the
end of the day
um
model optimization and software
optimization Choice uh
I love like divide and conquer approach
to code base like deep learning code
bases which means that
it's not a good idea to have like 1000
line class or module and to do that you
know everything in one instance what I
always
uh Lodge Forest okay we have this
inference right which consists of some
pre-processing some neural network
things some decoding things and some
post-processing things right okay let's
let's just package all these things and
let's try to optimize how many and which
workers should we use for each other
because there are some things probably
that's gonna need that's not gonna need
to be replicated because they take a
really small amount of time to
accomplish their job so you don't need
to replicate them in every instance you
will scale off right you can just have
one for let's say thousand neural
networks and you have like two decoder
for 10 neural networks and Etc
and refactor
yeah it's not a really good joke but uh
like Jim Keller uh
Jim Keller is watching for from what
what I have here don't like uh videos
and podcasts always saying if you want
to do a really good job at bidding other
companies you should refactor the CPU
design every three to five years
and he's talking about CPU design right
if you think about it probably you can
refactor your like 2 000 lines of calls
every like six months right it's not
gonna be a huge job but what it's got
what it's gonna lead you to is
when you're grubbing having other people
and coming and running your software
easily and working on different parts in
parallel and you'll be having easier
time to do extra accelerations and extra
features uh if you just keep
refactoring your code base and adapting
to nearest better techniques and newests
in a library versions
and last uh really really subjective
slide is that
basically a couple of advice this is
really important to invest in hardware
for researchers because more Hardware
you have faster we'll go
you should really refactor your code you
should not have a legacy code for one
year
avoid relying on high-level OS libraries
in production because they're gonna
struggle here somewhere in the future
when you have to scale and their own
networks and are really intuitive so if
you have opportunity to do that I mean
it could take some risk because it will
get higher rewards and last things
getting and then keeping Talent Happy is
a key and we could see that from many
many companies like from small companies
to really huge companies right
yeah that's pretty much it yeah thank
you
do it yeah
uh thank you for presentation I have
um many questions the first question uh
finally did you use uh buff to work as a
base model right yeah
uh did you compare your system with uh
Excellency yeah
oh yeah sorry finish and Allah sir uh
this uh this was the first question yeah
so
wave to work firstly came with like base
model which is 19 million parameter uh
Network and came with xlsr 53 which is
300 million Paramount Network then on
the second iteration it came with xlsr
300 right so you have 300 million power
button of network which was trained not
on 60 000 hours of data but on 400 000
hours of data right and you have three
versions of that 300 million param one
billion and two million so yeah we had
to of course do a search for which is
acceptable for uh our specific use case
scenario right but that included
engineering research and like business
side as well because you have to just
you you have to scale those huge models
right
okay uh the second question did you use
language model on the top of stt yeah of
course
um
so
one of the most uh
preferred ways to decode the ASR outputs
right now is KLM engram language models
right they're easy to optimize compared
to Transformer decoders Transformer
decoders are really really really
expensive to use and really expensive to
scale so if you really optimize the KLM
probably you'll be having you know
really good results and really on par
results with traffic transfer on records
the research is too slow in production
um
yeah beam search is really slow
but
you can do it in C plus plus and you can
do it in parallel right so you can scale
off on number of workers because CPU is
pretty cheap compared to GPU and you
know if you use like multi-threaded
optimized team search on CPU it's gonna
cost you a really small amount of money
to do that in parallel
okay and the last question uh how did
you resolve a problem with alphabets in
diverse languages maybe did you uh
did you do transliteration into
light ensembles
ah sorry
ah you're talking about alphabet right
yes alphabets and transliteration well
uh not transliteration but uh idea is
that you should either stick to uh
uppercase or lowercase right
I mean probably you could do both but
you could do uh casing afterwards as a
process processing step right and there
are many different languages for
instance like English is word based
Japanese is not right it's character
based so how do you optimize that well
the answer is
if the language you're looking for has a
huge amount of characters
like
probably like 20 of those characters are
used like content portally right so
they're using all the characters so I
mean we're trying to keep the character
amount of characters to a minimum amount
like minimum viable amounts but what
we're doing is basically you know
encoding and using all the characters
you know in PDP format and how many
tokens as a result for all languages
it depends on the architecture for
instance for wave to egg you have small
amount of reduction which is 320 right
and 320 reduction in the input sequence
size doesn't give you a really good
opportunity to use like pipe level
encoding on or WordPress right so
probably you're better off doing like
character level right Carter level but
Armenian uh for example has our own
alphabet and many languages uh is way
deeper from all lights and samples yeah
and I think this is a problem because
[Music]
Mania tokens no
if you do character level your number of
topics you're alphabet right
so like that answers the question right
pretty much oh let's say like for
Georgian like we have 33 letters in
alphabet right that's the token size if
you use character level uh ASR right
right thank you
[Applause]